I just don't think people understand how
Hard you have to work to make your dreams become a reality
freshman year in college
Me and my boys start like this like Christian like organization and my first message was pimpin ain't easy
But somebody's got to do it. That's my first master church meeting. Yeah the church me. I don't want to be on crack
I've never drank. I never smoked and I'm not against it
I just didn't do it because my family was doing it and they wasn't winnin doing it
Need motivation watch the top 10 with the beat nation. What's that belief nation? It's Evan
My one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level talent at
Something and I want you to find it embrace it and use it to make a difference
so let's get your motivation to attend and get you believing in you grab a snack and join today's lessons for men who went from
Dropping out of high school and being homeless on the streets of Detroit to becoming a best-selling author
inspired millions of people around the world and being one of the top motivational
speakers on the planet is Eric Thomas and here's my take on his top ten rules of success vol 6 also if you want to
Hear what Eric Thomas and other successful entrepreneurs have to say about building confidence
Check out my 250 for confidence series where every day for the next
254 days
I will send you a 30 second to 5 minute video for free in the morning to help you build unstoppable
Confidence the link to sign up is in the description below. I have a ritual where
even if you're my closest friend, I
Have boundaries, so just because it's my company. It doesn't mean I can take calls all day, right?
I have boundaries so you can't call me in a certain time why I'm working. You got to make a sacrifice
If you're gonna get you to the next level
You're gonna have to give up something, right?
You're gonna have to give up
Something and I'm just gonna keep it real with y'all when I say give up when I talk about sacrifice
I'm saying give up your current blessings like it's gonna be hard
Give up the current blessings. Are you here? I'm telling you
I had to make a sacrifice when I've been telling you to get that gold get that dream
And I'm just been telling you drive it and drive it and drive it and drive it
What I've been talking about is consistency and for some of you for real for real, you'll never have it
You'll never be it. You'll never do it because you don't have any consistency
Okay, let's kick it off with rule number one pay the price I just don't think people understand how
Hard you have to work to make your dreams become a reality. You know, like I think people get so excited about the
Dreaming part that they have no idea like what it really takes and so I need to do me a huge favor
I need you to understand number one that every dream you have will become a reality
But the first thing you realize you have to realize is you will have to pay the price
There is a price tag to greatness. It's not free. They not handing it out your mama
Can't give it to you your daddy can't give it to you, but god bless the child. That's got his home
And so I was in Montgomery last week guys, and I went to the opening of the new Memorial
And they showed the different individuals who had been lynched and why they had been lynched and what county they came from?
And as I was in my government seeing Rosa Parks listen to me very carefully guys
Oh listen to me, very carefully. She had to pay a price and so they said to Rosa you can't see here
Rosa said I'm gonna pay the price they said if you do not get up
Rosa said I ain't getting up. I've been working real low. I've been working real hard
I'm not getting up and they arrested her and guess what Rosa is great, but she's pray to pay the price
So what makes it special for me is that Rosa Parks is not only an icon Rosa Parks
Not only represents
having a dream and
Not only having a dream but having to grind for that dream like going to prison for that dream having to walk
381 days
Plus for that dream. I want to say to the Millennials. You are not entitled to anything
You are not if you go get anything you will have to work
But every single thing you get and you got to work every single day rule number two find your gift
When did you know? Hey, this is something different about me. I can really speak here
This is something unique freshman year in college. Don't laugh. Alright freshman year in college
Me and my boys start like this like Christian like organizations or every Tuesday Thursday and Sunday
We'd speak now. They didn't let me speak initially. Okay, because I was a high school dropout rough around the edges
Like I wasn't really polished right and so but here's a good thing is, you know
You stay home was a gift. So we did it every Tuesday Thursday Sunday
So at some point the guys couldn't make the appointment
So I was like always the host of the show, so when they didn't show up, yes
They like when we bring in surah so to speak I'm like nah. No, you're not. I'm hosted
So this is my shot right here. The best of villain ability is availability, right everyone there Trey wedding there
I'm like finally three four months into it. I'm like, I'm no I mean cuz they got
I don't what do you mean, you know, and my first message was?
Pimpin ain't easy, but somebody's got to do it. That was my first message church meeting you had to church me
I Pippin it easy, but somebody's got to do it
I said don't laugh but but this is how I knew I had something because people were like yo
Nobody's ever. And so I talked about how the devil is trying to pimp us
and and you know
And I just took that whole angle and in my second message just blew up
Was how many licks does it take to get to the center of a sucker?
You know, and so everybody was just like yo, right it's different like this is not a normal
Preacher it's not the normal delivery. The energy is kind of different. So wild. Ult's weren't really fooling with me
A lot of guys who were like, oh really do that church stuff. I won't do that kind of stuff
We're not into that and what was unique about and I'm glad you asked nobody's ever asked me is
What was unique is that we did at the bell tower, which was in the center of the campus
So you had to pass it to go anywhere
So it was cash like you I wasn't coming to no spiritual event, but I would hear that loud
voice and that passengers and I heard
You know so they would just walk over like yeah
What is he talking about pimpin ain't easy and it was at that point when I saw non church regular people
Jeans t-shirts coming by and when I would speak stop I was like yo e you got you got something
Yeah, you got something rule number three wanted bad enough. I need you to wanted as bad as you want to breathe
Listen to me very closely
Listen to me when I wrote my dreams and my goals down look when I wrote my dreams and my goals down take a look
At it guys when you want to succeed as bad as you want to breathe. I'm telling y'all
I'm telling y'all the 4-year degree the masters the PhD when I went after it, I'm showing you right where I graduated from
That's why I'm standing here because I need y'all to see it
I need y'all to see where I watched across the stage just where I did it y'all I wanted it as bad as I wanted
To breathe I got up in the morning and I walked them down. Give me before I get out of here
You ain't got it when you you ain't got it had a best and in life. I'm leaving you with this
You ain't gotta had the best hand in life. You ain't got to start with the two-parent background
You ain't got to start with wealth. You ain't got to start with your parents graduated
It's not the hand that you dealt
You got rich kids who own drugs you got rich kids who committed suicide?
You got rich kids who who don't know their purpose in life. It's not the hand that you were dealt, baby
It's how you play your hand. It's your boy et. Sin if it was easy to do. Everybody would do it
I'm not saying it's gonna be easy, but you have what it takes if you listen it to make it happen
So do me a favor get up get out and go get something with rule number four have big dreams
I want you to live the life you were meant to live
You hear me? Not the life that was given to you
I'm a high school dropout cuz that's the life. My daddy gave me
But I've been married almost 28 years and two kids by the same woman, which is not my experience
I got brothers and sisters. None of us had the same parents
Because I made up in my mind
That's the life. Y'all gave me. I'm not I'm not taking that no more. I don't want I don't want to be on crack
I've never drank. I never smoked and I'm not against it
I just didn't do it because my family was doing it and they wasn't winning doing it
Uncle died of cirrhosis of the liver. I'm like bruh. I'm not going out like that. Uncle's in prison
I'm not going I wasn't meant to be in prison. I
Got married in 19 y'all's meant to live with a woman. I'm not I'm not
I ain't mad action where I'm just being real. It's some dudes they like I'm hardcore. I'm not hard
I promise you I'm not hard. I want to be with no dudes all day every day. I just I'm gonna need a break
I'm gonna need a break from that. I'm just being real
I'm gonna need a break for me and my man in the same bump and I ain't got no privacy
I'm gonna need a break from that. I'm just being real. I'm gonna need a break from prison food
I'm gonna need my grandma cooking at some point
I'm just being real just be honest when you walk out of here. Some of you are not transitioning
Because you okay with the life you have and I'm telling you right when I walk out
I want to be an example of you can start from wherever and get to where ever you want to get to that's what I'm
Asking you to do what fuels you?
The reason why you so lazy is not because you don't have the ability you so lazy because your dreams so small
Rule number five get to know people for me
It's like when you get around people and you spend enough time with people
To see what people want and then you give them what they need
To me, that's what it's all about, you know, so it's like we got to get out of this
This is what I want to talk about her
This is what I want to say or this is how one it's like no my idols mother Teresa
Like I use just to watch her movement, right?
And she was the lowest of a pecking order when you talk about preaching with an archbishop. She wasn't the Pope
She was a nun
Oh, yeah
You know who she is and I would watch her and she would see okay here the needs of the people
When I watched my Luther King
This dude could have easily been like a millionaire living in a he moved and with the people and said hey
I'm gonna give up my life and what I want to do to help so for me
It's like you can't affect a person if you don't know what they want
So you guys spent enough time with people just chilling with people hanging out with people. That's what I was geet
It's like it's not a studio. I'm like yo, where's crib this gonna be phenomenal
Just because they eat those like we're your house this way you live
Like I said his energy already ended in the space, you know and spirits, you know already in the place
So for me, it's like you gotta get to know the people
Yeah, spend time with the people and then once you find out what they need you like a cow
You chew it up. Chew it up. Chew it up. Chew it up
You study it you study
And then when you get to them you give them what they need
And of course, they're gonna be excited because what they need rule number, six take the shot
Stop saying I'm not good enough. Stop saying my family
We don't do this like stop with the excuses and take the opportunity that's given to you. Shoot the doggone shot you wide open
Take this shot. I need you to hear me very carefully
When he told me I would be great
I never shared this with my friends
But I will wake up in that abandoned building and I would pretend that I was gonna be great
As I walked up and down those lonely streets. I would pretend to myself and I was gonna be great
I need you to be a favor before the actual dream becomes a reality. I need you to wake up every single day
I need you to eat the dream. I need you to sleep to dream
I need you to talk to dream because some days you're not gonna feel like getting up and the dream is gonna push you some
Day, you're not gonna feel like keep going. But the dream is going to push you rule number seven. Don't be envious
Don't be envious of individuals who in your life your homeboys your homegirls
Like we're not talking about haters right now with so much your people. You love not looking at everybody else's life right now
Y'all guys do me a favor. You gotta be trouble vision, right?
UK are my man doing this my homegirl doing this she graduated and got a job
I don't got a job in life. She fries written and my man prospers. I'm done look listen to me
Don't give me nobody else had the hand that life dealt them. Don't give me nobody else my boy
Joey kid with my sophomore year. He left college right went to go sing with tape six grant Grammy
Award-winning take six. Are you hearing me? I never went to my boy critter hated on my boy when I went I was like
Dude, I was like not only in my dreams like in my head
Not only am I dream something I'm talking about but I got a homeboy who doing it rule number eight do it for the love
Look this was wrong with this generation
If you're doing it for money you cutting it on and all hmm
If you're doing it for money, if they ain't giving you bread that mean you ain't gonna come clean
Yes, that mean you ain't gonna give 120%
So that's why I do it for the love of the game because that just means every time I do it
I'm gonna be fired who make the most money the the
Basketball player not that could put up 40 the dude that could put up the big numbers and do it consistently
I can't pay gonna put up 30 in one game. Then he gonna put a five in another one. Mmm
I can't build my team around
Inconsistency, but if you could score 17 a night and I know you can give me that 50 games out of 82 I can reveal
Something around that so for me young people listen to me
You temper minnow if you can only do it for money and if you temper minnow
It just don't mean I'll get I don't know when I can count on you and we can't make money if I don't know when
I can count on your shoes. So for me, it's
That's why I was at the camp murdering it because I don't know who in the room who could give me another opportunity
rule number nine surround yourself with greatness
What is it that you did that's separate issue from everybody else that did what you did?
So you're motivational speaker, and there are other people in the game and I respect everything mentioned everybody who follows you
But what exactly did you do that separated you and your work ethic and everything else?
So the first thing I did was literally a lot of people go to church I built a relationship with the creator. I
Said look, I'm gonna put you first I messed up. Apparently, I didn't know I didn't do it, right
I'm gonna give you a shot now to run my life and don't do don't mess it up. Like I messed it up
So I'm giving it to you fully. We're not gonna play with it. You can have it completely
Second thing I did was I got with didi my wife when I was in in church
Relationships are everything who you hang with? Yeah, who you hang with who you who you make your right hand?
That's that I don't care nothing about read and study and doing it outlook that not to do it
Nothing you you are nothing but the sum total of the people that you're closest to
All right
So you got to get with the right I got with Dee and didi said look
I'm going to college you a high school dropout when I go to college
I'm not dating no high school dropout you either get a GED and follow me to college. I'm breaking up with you
The first word I use when I came out and I talked about gas and the car was what
fuel
That was fuel bruh
I'm not looking to me I might be stupid, but I ain't done
It's being real. I might be stupid, but I ain't dumb bro
I knew my girl were about to go to no college for four years
Yes
Huh, yo said I stupid she bout to go to college before year around all them dudes
Who want to be doctors and lawyers and teachers and gonna come back to me and for she not gonna graduate and come home so
A high school dropout and be like I'm back. I
Was like the only way that
I'm gonna keep her as go get this GED and follow and so I'm telling you you hang around the right people
They will give you dreams for yourself that you didn't have for yourself
they will create expectations for you that you didn't expect and then
Finally what makes me different than anybody else is when you get the opportunity
From day one you stay you get hungry day one and you stay hungry
and rule number ten my personal favorite and also the last one before a very special bonus clip is be
intentional
Everything is intentional come on and take you know
You got to be intentional and deliberate and everybody that's running what you got to be intentional deliver
See, this is what I don't do
I don't hang with people you can only get up when they got something to motivate you
That's not something I wanna hang out with I want to hang out with the dude in Boston. You can kill them and
Detroit you can kill them in
Toronto you can bring the noise
Are you here when I'm telling you? I wanna hang with somebody. I don't care what the circumstances I don't care
What the situation you put it on your back and you like let's go
I don't run with people who count on me and put our 50-point. I remember people put up video
I put up Viki that put up and we murder you look like that's why I respect Mike
Sorry, I'm gonna get some highlight dog
Magic was the man Larry Bird with the man
Doubront come on Black Mamba the man we'll go back and look at some highlights
Y'all y'all go back and look at the highlights - MJ go look at the highlights. Oh look at that intensity
My man head go look at the highlights. Watch Jordan
Y66. He's trying to hear this boom and looked at you like boom
He would shoot a duck. He's the only one that make a jet. He started that he's making saying assassinate you
Just only one jump only one in history who are done for you it didn't stop you
The only one offensive
Massacre and defensive assassination. I'll take it from you. I'll rip it for you and you're watching me go down. Boom
Now I make your crowd shut up. I'll take them off the game where you'll hear me but at it doll
I've got a really special
bonus Eric Thomas clip on how to keep pushing that I think you're really gonna enjoy but before that I want to make sure you're
Moving from just consuming a video to actually taking action
So I have three thought-provoking questions for you to ask you can write them down for yourself in a notebook
You can talk about them with a friend or leave them in the comments below ready. Here we go
Question 1 what do you need to be more intentional with in your life question number two?
What can you do to surround yourself with more greatness and question number three? What are you going to take your shot on that?
You're afraid to do. Thank you guys so much for watching. I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in yourself and whatever. Your one word is much. Love. I'll see you soon. And enjoy the bonus clip
I'm emotional almost in tears
you know, I saw like the manifestation of
You know DD and eyes like we put in and work with our kids right and I remember being in that hospital room
You know 22 years almost 23 years ago when Jalen was born, you know, you got dreams for your kids, you know
There are certain things you want to see your kids do accomplish, etc
and it came full circle, you know, my son was responsible for putting together the
Triple-double academy. That's right, the triple-double Academy and this is something that's dear to my heart
I've been trying to get this nonprofit off the ground on this level for a long time, you know
And then I'm proud of my son. He made it happen. I'm talking about you should have seen him running around
You know him getting involved with the kids. You know, I'm sad just phenomenal to date
Like I said, man, I'm in tears, you know and a lot of camps. It's just about basketball. That's it
But this was my body and soul
This was a camp that helped kids not only on the court but off the court, you know
He had a workshop for parents and then they had workshops for kids
We had people from you know engineers to NFL players, you know
The two basketball players like you you had a plethora of people from all walks of life that were in the building
You know helping these kids out so man. It was a phenomenal two-day event
Like I said, I'm a proud father again, man. Triple double Academy. It went from a vision
it went from an idea to
Manifestation. Yeah, so it's your boy eating saying dreams do come true. Right so I just needed to keep pushing
He brought it and one day you're gonna wake up in the midst of your dream
Altruistic world domination honey Empire right? I'm grateful
I understand why I'm here I think because I am so open I wanted to think unseen. It's a bloody brief life
All of you have the potential for enormous
success if you want to know what Gary v-d-j Khalid Oprah and others know about
Empire building that most people miss check out the link in the description for a free bonus video